it really excites me to see when when we
come and go on a customer call and they
tell us so what's new and we show them a
new capability that we built or
delivered and they said oh God I didn't
realize that this is what I needed but
this is really what I needed and this is
great that you came with this because I
didn't know how to kind of express my
specific need entrepreneurs need to be
very good they're product people in
order to shape the right strategy and
product strategy within the company
to 20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders today with
Yoni shokhet a seasoned entrepreneur
with a successful track record in the
Israeli cyber security landscape you
only received his bachelor's of Science
and Mathematics at the age of 19 and
completed his service in the Israel
Defense Forces as a cyber security team
leader and project manager at one of
Israel's most esteemed Military
Intelligence units valence is the second
cyber security starter Pioneers founded
following his time as CEO and co-founder
of scad Defense a Pioneer in industrial
iot cyber security
thank you very much for spending this
time with me and I'm really excited to
dive into your own Journey your journey
cyber security valence SAS security what
even guide you into cyber the first
place and your serial entrepreneur in
the cyber space so this is not doing you
know it's not just a new hobby of yours
this is something that you've been
dedicating a quite a bit of time and
energy into and so let's start there you
know take me back Yoni what prompted you
into this cyber security scene
yeah so I think I always was looking to
to challenge myself even as a teenager
so I started my bachelor's degree when I
was 16 in mathematics and I finished it
right before the kind of mandatory
Israeli military service Union as well
and by the age of 16 and age of 19 I
already had a bachelor's degree and I
joined uh I lead to a cyber unit and and
from there kind of took me into the
cyber world and into more of the
technology-oriented world of cyber
research and on how to do a how-to-day a
Packers think and operate in the modern
world and how influential it is across
the board uh I know everything we do on
our day-to-day life and from there
once I finished my military service as a
captain after about six years
um I started my first startup called
skate offense focused on my industrial
iot cyber security and helping
manufacturing and critical
infrastructure companies to secure their
operational technology environments and
about the 18 months ago I started the
valence which is my second cyber
security startup focused on really on
SAS security
so you know so take me back 18 months or
so you have a you know quite a bit of
experience on field and you're looking
at the different opportunities that
there are in this type of space and
we're we're at you know in 2021 what's
happening in in the landscape that
you're as if you're putting yourself
back in that seat what understandings do
you have about the world we're in that
lead you to sort of focus with feelings
yeah so I think I always joke that the
cyber security startups are sometimes
like a mushroom after the rain so there
was a large breach at the end of 2020
called solarwinds a breach campaign
where which exposed a lot of weaknesses
in today's modern cyber security
ecosystem and and what they triggered
for me the the most interest is really
the third party risk element and the
fact that today we're so dependent on
third-party services and vendors that
have high privilege access and high
privilege capabilities to access our
data or privileges our day-to-day
business processes and this is a LED
within that attack campaign to different
weaknesses within a modern Enterprise
security and tax services
that really prompt us to focus on what
valence started with which is really
more focused on how do we Grant access
to third-party vendors to our
environment and from there it evolved to
how to even trust these third-party
services and how they're configured and
how they're properly managed to use by
different business users across the
organization
right and so what you're talking about
is much more collaborative collaborative
microservice third-party integration
approach
well if we're looking at the the
situation today in the software space in
terms of companies what are the
different vulnerabilities that have
emerged as a result of the changing
landscape going from on-prem to cloud
and having so many of these new service
providers come up
yeah so I think about a decade ago if
you would look a lot of cyber security
attacks and breaches a lot of them
focused on zero days and on
vulnerabilities and on very complex
software issues and vulnerabilities but
today attackers don't really need to
hack all they need to find is find the
right the account or find the right
credential or find the right access
token and from there they can get access
to high privilege systems and to just
properly configure their way all the way
until they were able to eventually
perform their malicious action or to get
access to the data that they're after
and the the ecosystem is really changing
because we no longer need to think about
just the sophisticated attack that is
leveraging a very high-end technology
capability but how do we protect from
our day-to-day misconfigurations that we
can perform today in these Cloud
environments where we don't own most of
the infrastructure we own very a very
small portion of the infrastructure but
the shared responsibility model is
Shifting all the responsibility to the
customer side to properly manage and
configure these SAS applications
and it's kind of technology is
democratizing and decentralizing we're
starting to see more and more entities
within the businesses whether it's a
developers or marketing teams or sales
teams or it or HR that are now able to
build and configure logic within the
organization which is great for the
business you can innovate and run fast
but it also creates a lot of
opportunities for these types of
misconfigurations that attackers can
leverage today within the within the
environment
and so how does how does valence come to
that
yeah so what we've learned over the
since we started valence is that for
most of our customers the biggest
challenge is not to know about more
problems I've heard again and again from
Security leaders I don't want to get
visibility into problems that I cannot
solve what the security teams care the
most today about is how do they show
effective risk reduction over time so
not only how do they show hey I know
about all my problems and I have a nice
map of my wrist surface but how do I
effectively apply the proper remediation
controls and the proper risk mitigation
over time to eliminate risk within the
environment so what we've built is that
if it what we understood is that if
eventually a staffs in our case is
adopted and democratized and
decentralized manner it only makes sense
to have the proper decentralized and
democratized Remediation workflows
within the organization that allow the
security teams to engage and collaborate
with the different business users within
the organization to remediate risks
whether if it's identity security risk
data protection
third party Integrations
misconfigurations across the board
within your SAS environment like
Salesforce and Google workspace and
Microsoft 365 and slack and GitHub and
often all these different business
critical SAS applications
do you have a sort of a snowball effect
as you are able to understand the
different test applications and and how
they're configured and so as the
approach being M plus q1 company that
you're selling to you're coming in with
the bulk of knowledge in other words is
there transferred knowledge between you
know as you work and as you progress
yes I think one of the core value
pillars that we provide is the Outsource
expertise so to say so we reduce the
level of expertise that each security
team needs to have within each one of
these applications because eventually a
lot of these applications have a lot of
overlap and similarities but also a lot
of differences and for a security team
to understand how do you define a
certain configuration or permissions set
in Microsoft 365 compared to how it's
configured in Salesforce compared to how
it's configured on slack last year on
zendesk and all these core stocks
applications it's very complex it
requires a lot of knowledge it requires
a lot of hands-on experience with these
Platforms in a lot of cases the security
team doesn't even have access to these
platforms they don't know how the
interface even looks like and we
simplify their ability to not be the
expert in each one of these SAS
applications but to even to be able to
Define their desired state in their own
language and that is security language
and to help apply it on a continuous
basis within their environment of SAS
applications
and so how do you how do you see this
evolve now so you're looking at valence
18 months and where where are you at
today and where where how are you
evolving right now
yeah so we started with a very narrow
focus in terms of uh the problems that
we're trying to solve and we're adding
more and more capabilities within our
platform and eventually while we're
building what we have today is a staff
security a platform that helps security
teams not have to adopt and install
install multiple different security
controls or Security Solutions in order
to secure the different a a risk
surfaces that they have within SAS
applications but to be de-step security
platform that helps you get the
visibility you need and to be able to
remediate the risks properly by engaging
and collaborating with business users
across the board within the organization
so this process really allows you to get
an end-to-end capability that covers and
checks all the boxes whether it's
compliance misconfiguration management
is supply chain risk reduction or
whatever it is within your SAS
applications and over time we will
evolve to be more and more D platform
for SAS application application and the
One-Stop shop for all the security needs
within it
so you know we're talking about
platforms One-Stop shops I mean this
this requires a lot of trust and and
engagement from from obviously the
people that are bringing valence into
their own system that requires that they
really put their their trust and faith
with you and not just to solve a niche
problem in their security Gap but really
for for the whole uh SAS security
how do you build that trust how do you
get to a position where you can come
into an organization and say I'm your
platform I'm your One-Stop shop
obviously it's an amazing Congressman
but how do you even get there from a
from a a relationship perspective with a
customer
yeah that's a great question I think
that when we started then we were just a
shlomi my co-founder myself and we
started working with our early design
Partners uh and we we asked to access
their platforms and to better understand
how the risk surfaces looked like and
they they looked at us and they said
okay you're just a two-people company
how can we trust you so we build
Technology Solutions that allowed to
reduce the friction and the the level of
trust that is needed to prove our value
one step at a time until we earn more
and more of their trust and open up the
ability to for them to enjoy our actual
benefits but for us to also justify
their trust and we invested early on in
the best practices in terms of security
compliance privacy and everything else
and I think today like you mentioned 18
months in we're already backed with by
some of the best investors in the
industry so Microsoft's M12 LED our
series a together with participation of
Akamai and Porsche Avengers which is it
shows a lot of a very respectable a
corporates and Enterprises within the
world that did their vetting system him
and said valence is our bid for the
2b.stat security platform and especially
when it comes from security vendors or
from a leading Enterprises or from SAS
vendors this is a very significant
statement within the within the market
and also with help with the early
advisors and investors so we have some
of the best csos of the in the world
that invested in the company early on it
really helps to say these people are
legit and they they can be trustworthy
and kind of a more of a transitive
manner of the if I trust them then I can
trust the people that they trust them
is there a quantitative way to be to
create comparisons between companies or
or some Benchmark mechanism to be able
to determine how different companies
fare in in this world of yours
yeah so I think it's a it's pretty
challenging because it's still a lot of
companies are still in the startup mode
so you need to reduce the noise ratio
between what they say they do and what
they actually do because good
entrepreneurs can create Magic to think
as if they built the world even though
they haven't done it yet so I think it's
very challenging in the maturity of the
current market that we're playing in but
obviously as the market evolves there
are more of a third party at the station
companies like Gardner and others
now try to provide some kind of a
comparison and create some kind of a
this criteria that you can check boxes
accordingly but we still see that today
a lot of the questions that we received
from a from the market are are still not
in a mature state that will allow to
Define I would say a good good criteria
that you can judge the environment
accordingly
right everything that makes sense and
ask you if we're looking at this
industry growing obviously this is
something that every company is going to
need even if they don't already think so
um how are you imagining valence down
the line we mentioned platform One-Stop
shop if you're imagining sort of The
Suite of businesses around the world
that are that are relevant here
what is the relationship that you'll
have with them as they're preparing to
to onboard some vendor of how are you
positioning valence as the vendor for
this
yeah so I think today a lot of the
businesses and especially security teams
when they adopt a Mr breed SAS
applications because they don't have
good control in governance measures and
the bright guard rails to guide their
users they try to block everything so
they say you can use Microsoft 365 but
you cannot share files on OneDrive it's
all only share internally or you cannot
use this function or you cannot use that
function you cannot create Integrations
you cannot use tokens and it really
limits the scope of the value of these
platforms and as organizations are going
through the first phase of moving
towards SAS and are starting to evolve
to become more modern SAS native and
orientation they will need to start
opening up a lot of these limitations
that they're putting in otherwise the
business will find workarounds because
historically what we've seen is that if
a security team defines something that
is inconvenient for a certain team
within the organization so like let's
say with developers then they'll find a
workaround to get what they want because
they care only about the business and
they want to make sure that the business
is successful not because because
they're bad or malicious and security
teams will have to adjust to how do they
how do they how do they want to be the
enablers and to work together with their
business their users in order to allow
them to feel more secure to so to
educate them to empower them and to
allow them to run fast and to use the
platforms but to ensure that if they go
too much to the right too much of the
left and there are the proper guard
Wheels to keep them in place and to
focus on what matters in terms of not
only the business and the value but also
the security aspect
and it just from involvement for the
security teams why are you still and
exciting and interested in what you do
what what's in it for you yeah so I like
to build stuff and I like to to to make
to kind of feel that I have the an
influence uh on my day-to-day I love
working and I love my I love my job and
I I love to put in the hours and put in
the effort to make a everybody that is
kind of influenced by our company uh
satisfied so it obviously it starts with
kind of our our employees and the
internal team and it goes through our
customers Partners investors an entire
ecosystem that we're kind of working
with to make sure that they're properly
satisfied from the value and the in what
we're providing we're not looking to
kind of be a platform that you hate but
you have to buy or something like that
we want to make sure that we solve a
real pain this is why we're very
customer obsessed in everything that we
do and that we really listen and work
with our customers and make sure that we
properly adjust according to the
evolvement of what they need
and luckily enough we had great early
Believers in that term and that helped
really shape the vision of what we're
now establishing within the market
because we were able to really listen to
their problems and to evolve and extend
our vision and to expand it to New areas
and problem spaces and really excites me
to see when when we come and go on a
customer call and they tell us so what's
new and we show them a new capability
that we built or delivered and they said
oh God I didn't realize that this is
what I needed but this is really what I
needed and this is great that you came
with this because I didn't know how to
kind of express my specific need but if
you listen enough to the ecosystem into
the environment you can really find the
right the right pain points that you
need to tackle and usually entrepreneurs
need to be very good they're product
people in order to shape the right
strategy and product strategy within the
company
so the the leap from being a builder and
being Satisfied by these new new
advancements and the new insights there
there's still not enough to go on a
crazy entrepreneurial Journey twice so
where where is that coming from
yeah I think that once you go
entrepreneurs very difficult difficult
to go otherwise you just mentioned that
you started a company recently I think
you'll see it there definitely firsthand
it's very difficult to do anything else
the level of excitement the level of
thrill the level of influence the
ability to every day do something that
you wouldn't believe that you would do
that day or that to tackle new problems
and even if it's to just a have the
ability and the flexibility to work all
around across the board with multiple
different elements so I can be one hour
a marketing person the other hour A
salesperson the third hour product
person a researcher a hard technology
problem I can go all around it really
allows me to I think
from my personal perspective to bring my
best of myself out but also to to
influence and help other people that are
surrounding us and that that can really
progress themselves whether it's for
another business or for their personal
career
I love that and and I I love the the way
that you're looking at the sort of the
the simple but but really standard idea
that once you started once you've always
very hard to do anything else because
you you realize the level is drill and
you constantly surprise yourself what
was the biggest leap from a leadership
perspective that you've observed
yourself whether it be your six years
and the IDS or with the two startups
where have you seen the biggest leap for
you in terms of your your own leadership
yeah I think that the when I shifted
from like let's say a well-structured
organization like the these are
intelligence forces to more of the
startup World although there are a lot
of similarities but I think what what
you need to realize is that the Ever
every day or every let's say short
period of time you need to assist and
understand what is the most influential
aspect that you can really help and
impact the company because you can't do
everything even though you want to do
everything and you need to have very
straight Focus or very a narrow focus on
what you're focused and what you're
going to work on today what is going to
be the big task that you're going to
work on today where does your team need
the more help most help where does your
team need you to back off from or
whatever it is internally within the
company and to really be able to focus
your your efforts and your in your
attention to the most influential
aspects I think this is a constant
challenge it requires you to be able to
measure very carefully what's going on
to know what's going on to understand
and maybe anticipate the next steps
especially in today's market economy
where it you know it's a there's a lot
of uncertainty regarding what's going on
so let's say fundraising over the past
few months and we just announced our
series a a couple a couple of weeks ago
a so fundraising is definitely uh what's
top of mind and it really now allows us
to focus and and to be able to maybe not
take a call calls with investors and
maybe focus more on building the
platform building the business
generating more revenue and making sure
that we build a sustainable long-term
business and being able to do this type
of balance and to make sure that one day
you do this another day you do a
completely different aspect it's
something that is a requires a lot of a
lot of self-awareness and a lot of
continuous measurement across the board
of what you are doing and what the other
team members within the company are
doing or not doing
phenomenal you only thank you so much
this is so enjoyable and best of luck
with the Journey of valence and the
night startup on the next startup I
really appreciate your time best of luck
thank you thank you very much for having
me
[Music]